good morning
you know when i uh i teach 6002 uh the
campus version in this
lecture hall what i what i used to three
years ago
and when i would say good morning all
the students will be very sleepy
i would say okay let's do it again i
didn't hear you but i won't do that to
you
welcome to uh welcome to learning with
moocs
we are delighted to host you in uh sunny
cambridge
and uh the weather guards promises that
uh there won't be rain for another
couple of days
uh before i pass it on to the real
business of the day to candace tell
um i wanted to take a couple of minutes
to uh to talk about
the other side of learning with moocs
so a lot of us go to conferences uh
myself included you know give a talk
give a paper
drink great coffee talk to folks and
then you go back home and
little do you realize you know the the
background effort that goes into it
the group of people that are smiling
but as somebody just said it's really
hysteria not really pleasure
but but uh so i want to take a few
moments just to talk about
talk about some of these people that
really made this conference happen
um in particular this one because this
is the first time
the learning with moocs workshop is
happening and the first time something
happens as you all know
or you may not know the hardest part
about it is the choices
choices are hard because everything is
new everything is a choice
and every decision that has to be made
could go this way
or it could go the other way and so as
you experience various things in the con
in the in the workshop one choice was do
we name it a workshop or a conference i
mean everything was a choice
and so uh so a number of people made a
bunch of choices
made a bunch of choices all along the
way and what you see here is a result of
those choices
and so let me spend a couple of seconds
acknowledging
the set of team members and people that
took the risks made these choices and
put this workshop together
let me start with acknowledging the
hewlett foundation
barbara chao are you here
uh barbara charles back there and uh uh
her uh
uh colleague uh who uh barbara and vic
woochick who was at hewlett foundation
in the early days helped conceive of
this idea
and uh and uh they not only provided the
funding for the workshop
but uh they were also very instrumental
in conceiving
coming up with the concept of what the
workshop should look like
there are academic conferences and there
are commercial conferences
the idea was to pull something together
that was
a combination where you get
practitioners and researchers and
teachers and educators and
learning designers and educators and
video producers all together
entire teams that make online courses
and education happen
and so uh what you see here is the
fruits of that and
i really would like to acknowledge you
the foundation not just for the funding
but also a lot for the thinking and the
insight
that uh and the drive that really helped
uh helped us pull this together
um i would like to acknowledge uh
someone amara singh
uh someone uh uh i'm gonna i am he's a
close friend of mine so i'm going to
embarrass him so can you stand up and
take a bow
so someone is the general chair of the
conference
and usually when something goes wrong
it's his fault
and so uh so uh as general chair
i think saman had to make some of the
most of the decisions
and when he would call one of us in the
steering committee
or elsewhere say okay what do i do and
the answer would be saman your program
chair of your general chair
uh make the general decision for the
conference and so uh so you can blame
him for
a lot of what is going on but just
tremendous amount of effort
uh saman put his heart and whose soul
into this
pulling the conference together and and
really
really made this happen i want to
acknowledge
candace still from stanford and oli
as program chair and her co-chair ross
trotter
and both candice and ross
if i can see them around i'll make both
of them stand and embarrass them as well
where's ross there you go
um as program chair uh uh co-chairs uh
candice and ross
uh pulled a program committee together
uh just uh just a who's who in education
and research and
uh and mooc practitioners and and really
spread the word about getting really
quality papers in and
and put the program together and even
there lots of choices
just give you a couple of examples of
hard choices
so what would you do would you have
sessions with
three 20-minute talks a piece or
10 or 15 three-minute talks or sessions
with
one talk and a discussion or a uh
davos style conference where you have
three people sitting in chairs and a q a
all of these are choices and so there
again if you look at the
the workshop program you will see
a very unique blend of choices now
i'll hold my judgment to the end of the
conference as to how successful it is
but again
there were risk takers they took some
chances they were bold
so i think you'll see some very unusual
formats hoping to
foster discussion and conversation and
it's just a fantastic program
my my only my only worry is that uh
these dang parallel sessions so many
good papers and these parallel sessions
i want to be at all of them so
try to think of how i can finally time
multiplex myself and run fast enough
between them to uh
to sample all of them but we'll find out
i want to acknowledge uh
unum o'reilly uh unum was the
finance chair for the conference um
unum is at csel and uh i also want to
acknowledge sea sale
and mit for providing a lot of help and
housing
for the conference you all got a lot of
email
a lot of great publicity for this
workshop and
and as the call for papers went out and
so on and want to acknowledge uh
kalyan veera machaneni and they just did
a spectacular job
again when the conference started we had
really no idea how do we
how do you go about starting something
new who do you you don't have an email
list
that you can send an email to and say
look we want to hold the conference
again
so next time around it's going to be
easier because now there is a
email list but the first time how do you
even start
so kalyan gets a lot of credit for
publicity
i want to acknowledge mary mcdevitt for
a lot of the local arrangements hotel
instruments and
so on want to point out
kathy levine kathy levine for
professional management of the
entire workshop but she's with mit
events just a phenomenal job uh
judy bosch of usenix again very gracious
really helped
get the word out about about this about
this conference
so with that uh let's give all of the
team members that made this happen
a quick round of applause
and with that let me welcome you all
again to
learning with moocs enjoy and let me
pass it on to
candace still who will talk about the
program and the rest of the workshop
thank you
okay great so thank you all for coming
um i agreed to be the program chair
for this workshop because i believe in
education i believe it is the core
of social progress and i can see by
your attendance that you share that
belief and
the as we all know higher education is
under some pretty strong
pressures tuition and fees continue to
outstrip inflation
global demand far exceeds our capacity
and the completion rates of those that
most need it are unacceptably low
and into this context came moocs
and the promise of moocs was learning
at scale and the excitement
that that fostered was great and focused
on education in a way that we haven't
seen
in years unfortunately the focus for the
first couple years was on the
at scale part and now
we think it's time actually past time
to focus on the learning part
and so that's why we decided to have a
workshop and we designed the workshop
as a not talked about we made some real
choices
one of them is that everyone who is here
has been invited
and you were invited because you have
something
important to contribute so we structured
the workshop
so that the people giving talks would
limit their talks either to 15 minutes
in long form sessions
or three minutes in lightning round
sessions
so that we have lots of time to
facilitate
discussion we have a diversity of
expertise
education researchers learning
scientists educators
technologists and we wanted to make sure
to create the space
to really have you interact with each
other and bring your experience and your
knowledge
to push the field forward so i would
encourage you
in these sessions to not just sit there
and listen
or do your email or whatever
but to actively participate and take
ownership
over this field which we are creating
um we've got some great speed keynotes
for you today and before i introduce our
first keynote
um i want to just go over a couple
logistics one of them is that they're
um uh unfortunately uh there's not a
locked
space it's an open space so i've been
asked to tell you not to leave your
laptops just lying around
because they will uh walk away
the second thing is that outside of each
of the rooms are the programs
so you can look at the on the easel to
see what's happening in that room
the third thing is we are having a
twitter feed
and on your program
is the uh account to twitter if you want
to follow the feed
and uh i think those are the big
logistics
one announcement which is we want to
continue the work
after the workshop and so there is a
mailing list that's being started by
a collection of researchers to keep
researchers in this space informed
so feel free to sign in for that mailing
list at the registration table
and i think those are all the
announcements and logistics
so now it's my great pleasure to
introduce susan singer
um so most of you uh probably know who
susan is
but i'm gonna just say
a brief word to introduce her which is
that susan is the division director in
the division of undergraduate education
at nsf
she's also the lawrence mckinney gould
professor in biology
and cognitive science at carleton and i
want
that's really important that susan is
one of those exemplary
scholars that bridges both the the depth
of the discipline
and learning and education and her work
um has she's pursued a career that
blends
education and science she served on
numerous committees and boards focused
on the improvement of science education
she's participated in six national
academy studies
including sharing the committee that
author offer authored america's lab
report
promising practices in stem
undergraduate education and discipline
based education research which i taught
a course
last quarter and i made all my students
read that report
please join me in welcoming susan
thank you so much for the opportunity to
join you today and what an exciting
opportunity
to think about where we can go in
learning in a new context
and as candice pointed out the world has
changed
dramatically with all the work on
online environments and you know who
thought we would have the federal
government hosting data jams and data
paloozas and
you know in the meantime we're talking
about college opportunity and college
cost and the
future of where research universities
are going
but the other piece that's been going on
is this whole
area of science of learning just
keeps growing and growing in all sorts
of ways
and yet in many ways we've been
operating on two parallel tracks
right we're having our science of
learning going forward
but we haven't taken full advantage of
figuring out how that can inform
learning online and likewise how is it
that we can
come up with a new approach to research
new research agendas to learn from this
online
environment so we want to be careful
that we're not
scaling practices that are not effective
right
and we want to be sure when we're doing
the research we're not asking trivial
questions or answering questions that we
actually already have
answers to so how do we bring these two
together which is what's so
exciting about being here with all of
you
today and my one ask as we go
through the the media we think about is
you know there are
students in our classroom today you're
only 18 once you're only a first-year
undergrad once so we want to do the best
we can for the students that are here
today
while learning for the students in the
future and i think that's a really
interesting challenge
so learning shifting right learning's
occurring
any place anytime what does this
paradigm
shift mean for how we move forward
we're starting to see blurring of
boundaries and it's not just the face to
face
versus the online learning it's formal
and informal
are coming together you see this with
more academic civic engagement moving
into classes
and you see that moving together with
citizen science well online learning is
a phenomenal way
to facilitate all of this have we
thought about how these puzzle pieces
come together and in the moocs that are
out there that's one of the ways we're
blurring this
boundary between k-12 and undergrad
and grad you know think about who's
taking these
moocs announce 106 hundreds of thousands
of students in his circuits class
they're not
all undergraduate students
so what do we really need to do and
i think as we look at learning
environments we we really have to
understand both the cognitive
and the affective foundations for
learning
not one or the other and we really need
to get in
and study these emerging contexts and
the tools for learning concepts and
skills and really begin to frame our
questions in this new world
we want to build environments that
afford new
impact learning opportunities and we're
thinking about all students
whether they're going into a specific
workforce area
or whether they're going to be part of
the general populace making informed
decisions in whatever area it is
they're engaging in in your course
so we've got a lot of disruption of foot
here right one of the great things about
moocs
in my mind perhaps one of the very best
things about moocs is across the country
people are talking about
learning in new ways faculty are
stepping up the plate and
really thinking hard about what's going
on in their classroom
virtual or bricks and mortar in a way
that hasn't happened before and how can
we capture that energy to really improve
education the other thing to keep in
mind is
most of the work in moocs now ray kind
of focuses on what we know about
behavioral theory kind of basic
motivating stuff and really hasn't dug
into all this exciting nexus of
what we're learning about the brain what
we're learning in education research
what we're learning
in the learning sciences it's a golden
opportunity to bring that together and
that's what i heard caddis challenge all
of us to think about today
so we actually do know a lot about
learning and i thought i would start
first with what we know about you know
how people learn
in general this is just a summary from
the nrc study how people learn
the really terrific book that came out
of cmu
on how learning works and then the
discipline based education research
report and lots of other places
but we've got to remember that all
learning starts
with prior knowledge very important to
think about in moocs that are
reaching so many people with so many
different prior learning experiences how
are we taking that
into account there's a lot of work yet
to be done on understanding motivation
but it's critical we need to think more
about how learners organize their
knowledge right how they make sense of
the world
and create new mental constructs how do
they put all those pieces
together again harking back to prior
knowledge
and we know how important targeted
timely feedback is
how do you create that in the world of
moocs there's some incredibly rich
opportunities that might not even exist
in in large like lecture format
classrooms like this
and then what do we do again about the
affective domain the climate
in the classroom um i think i could see
carolyn rose here all the really
interesting work that she's doing
thinking about
the social aspects of learning as well
and how do we help learners become
more metacognitive more thinking about
their own learning
and then taking responsibility to adjust
their learning
approaches how do we build those
supports in because we know
these things are all very very important
for effective learning
so a lot of this comes from what we know
about cognitive science
and in many ways what the learning
sciences are is they're
bringing cognitive science into the wild
right so you think about your classroom
as the wilderness and work of many like
erickson focus on developing expertise
and i'm
slowly going to begin to shift us from
thinking about learning in general to
thinking about undergrads because that's
primarily where the books
have hit and so the notion of developing
expertise moving from novice to expert
isn't that really the challenge of the
undergraduate years as you move into a
major move into a field and
true expertise takes you know there's
all sorts of estimates right
10 years 10 000 hours of practice so
you're not going to become an expert in
introductory physics
but you're going to move along the
continuum what's it going to take
to do that then there's a lot of other
things and some of this comes from the
work of mark mcdaniel and his colleagues
at washington
university where they've spent the last
decade really working hard on pushing
cognitive science into the classroom and
pointing out that you know we we have a
lot of
um intuitions about learning we did as
students our students do and they work
against us sometimes
so we like to study and cram right
before
exams and it turns out that just
reviewing material over and over
doesn't work very well for increasing
retention you need to constantly
retrieve
so one of i think one of the really
interesting studies was done
with middle school science students but
it applies equally
i think to undergraduates done back in
where students were given over the
course of three semesters
three different kinds of strategies for
a third of the material
it was taught once and they were done
another third of the material
they were asked three different times to
review the material
and the other third of the material they
had
three quizzes spread out over time
and then at the end of three semesters
they looked at the overall success
with the students being able to master
and use that
information and whether they did just
the quick review or they saw it once
they they scored about 79 percent in
terms of understanding
where is the work where they did the
short quizzes very short quizzes the
instructor wasn't even in the room
92 percent success so we have to
practice
pulling things out of our memory
rereading things or like i have students
in my intro bio course that come in they
don't understand
why things went wrong in that exam
because here's the proof you know the
textbook and it's highlighted in
beautifully four different colors of
highlighter
and the whole thing is color and they
read it five times why didn't they do
well
we actually know from cognitive science
why they didn't do well
we also know that spacing out practice
and interleaving mixing
different types of work so you know
working on calc for a little while and
then going back
to your bio homework and then going back
to calc works much better than just
doing one thing over and over and over
or even within a specific course
breaking up the different kinds of
activities help with enduring memory
also elaboration so elaboration this
goes back to how do you construct your
own meaning
make sense in your own head of what's
doing so
you're taking the knowledge that's been
offered and you're translating
it you're piecing it together with other
knowledge you're actively working on in
your mind
all of this is saying using your brain
to actively engage with this
material so this is a great way to get
around the limitations of our short-term
memory right phone number started out
with seven
digits it's about how much we can hold
in our head
but if you're elaborating you're using
and connecting that knowledge you're
not limited by that working memory
constraint in quite the same way
and then this one just drives me nuts so
i had to get up on my thing
that you know you would not believe
how many times in the course of a month
i hear people talking about
catering to students learning styles and
cognitive psychologists have shown us it
really
doesn't work so for spending a lot of
time developing moocs thinking about
kinesthetic learners and visual learners
and auditory learners let it go
okay
it's so this that's a very quick
snapshot and i'm sure any cognitive
scientists out there would be horrified
about my you know cliff notes for that
but if we want to focus in on undergrads
right
all the supplies right your bra you
still carry around the same brain with
you it
changes and expands but it's still you
in different environments but what is it
about the undergraduate environment
so i want to take a few minutes and pull
from the discipline based education
research report some of the findings
there because i think it forms a frame
it focused on science and engineering
primarily because the research base
isn't as deep yet
in other disciplines and like that's
something that i think all of you that
are working in disciplines beyond
science and engineering
will be able to continue to add to the
the knowledge base
but the importance of deep disciplinary
knowledge
absolutely important in k-12 but
even more so in the undergraduate years
that if we're going to understand
learning and how people are we have to
understand in the context of the
discipline
and how people think and learn as it
relates to that discipline
and what the student's motivation is
to really work in that particular
discipline right and we've all heard
probably ourselves too
comment on affinity for different
disciplines or
different ways of thinking and knowing
in different disciplines what's going to
motivate people to fully engage
and then in this area all the research
methods the social science research
methods come into play being a terrific
physicist
does not make you an expert in doing
research on how your students learn and
how do we begin to think in terms
of teams again one of the other great
things about being here with everybody
today is the range of expertise that
we're bringing together
to figure out how we can leverage all of
this collectively
so what what are our goals and you're
going to hear me come back a few times
in the time this morning with you to say
what is it we're really trying to
achieve and the answer
may be different for different people
but you know within the undergraduate
years what what is this whole field of
discipline based education research
aiming
to do they want to understand how people
understand concepts and practices within
a discipline the nature and development
of expertise within
the discipline again the pro of the
primary challenges of the undergrad
years
how is it that you identify and measure
what are appropriate learning objectives
what is it that we really want students
to achieve and how are we going to know
if they've achieved that and it makes a
whole bunch of sense to reverse engineer
your course and start there
we still mostly fail to do that
and how is it that we translate
this learning into practice again the
great thing about
having a gathering where we're focused
on
practice is incredibly important because
all the research
the world isn't going to do us any good
unless it's being used to improve
the education and
how is it i mean this was one of the
original goals of moocs was to really
make
education abroad and inclusive are we
doing that
and what is it going to take to get
there so
there are a lot of things we do know
about how
undergraduates and others learn that we
can apply
to moocs and ought to be doing right now
for our students
we know a lot about students conceptual
understanding or lack of conceptual
understanding we know a lot about
problem solving
the use of representations and
instructional strategies that work
so in all disciplines no surprise
students have
enduring misconceptions they persist
even into
graduate school and it's particularly
hard
in spatial and temporal scales that are
very
tiny think about understanding molecules
are very large is it really a surprise
that evolution is hard to get your head
wrapped around over a large geological
time frame but there are strategies that
are effective in moving
students towards conceptual change once
you unpack
what the specific misconception is or
the the
piece that that's a sticking point and
again that's a real opportunity
when you start thinking about what might
be possible
with learning from moocs so i picked
this example because it's like a private
universe and there's a film that starts
in cambridge massachusetts asking
graduates
where does all the weight in this huge
chunk of oak come from
and college graduates you know are
saying in the roots in the roots versus
this is a photosynthesis question for
those of you who aren't thinking about
plant biology at the moment the carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere as well as the
water coming up from the roots but
it's very tough for students
adults of all ages to really visualize
that this huge amount of mass in a very
large oak tree
could come from the air and a huge
amount of work
has gone into helping students better
understand
photosynthesis what
finally was unpacked was the sticking
point
was how can air have mass air can't have
weight it just
didn't make sense but if you take
something really cool you could just do
it as a demo
right with dry ice which immediately
motivates and catches at least my
attention
you can help someone understand that dry
ice has mass
and then when it evaporates when it
sublimates
into the air it becomes easier to make
that
connection so once you understand what
the disconnect is
then you can help students move forward
in conceptual understanding
they also start out as novices in
problem solving areas doing a lot of
things that are very different than you
or i would as an expert within
our domain and expertise is domain
specific
right being a biologist doesn't suddenly
make me an expert in physics it
definitely doesn't
um novices pay attention to superficial
details they work
backwards the old can i guess what the
units are in this equation and work back
to that and on the other end of the
spectrum
experts have a blind spot we can't
remember what it was
like to be stuck and so this mismatch
this cognitive dissonance between the
two groups causes
challenges when we're thinking about
instruction and it may be why
peer-to-peer learning can be
so effective as a piece of learning
experience
so this goes back to 1981 mickey cheese
work but just to show
an example of focusing on superficial
details and this mismatch between the
way an expert in a novice looks at the
problem
this is asking students to take a set of
problems
at the end of a chapter in a holiday
resnick's
intro physics book and the novices all
put together the inclined plane problems
because they look alike
and the experts put together
conservation of
energy problems two different ways of
looking at the world
so we really want to think about you
know how did we get from here to here
and how can we help our students do that
we also need to think hard about
representations right the whole area of
visual analytics
is is moving forward this is work
laura novick at vanderbilt a cognitive
psychologist did with kevin
catley who is a evolutionary biologist
very interested in the shape
of figures diagrams how students look at
them
these are looking at evolutionary
relationships between different
organisms so just two different ways you
can present the same data
laura being a cognitive psychologist
said huh
the gestalt principle of good continuity
suggests a student's eye is going to
follow this
line and that's going to affect how they
interpret the results
and so they had students practice
solving interpretations of these
evolutionary trees solving problems
using the two different
trees and students were much more likely
to get the correct answer with this
version
than this version because their eyes
were following the slide
laura then went and looked at all the
introductory biology texts which reach
about 800
000 students every year and guess what
in about 2008
almost all the introductory textbooks
use lots of this version
in 2014 most of the introductory
textbooks now use this so a small
little piece of research has changed the
learning experience of
many students you also know about
perhaps
cluttered diagrams right if you have a
you're looking at inclined plane
problems
and you have a skier going down a slope
if you put a cute little hat and all
sorts of things that make it really
interesting
you actually distract the learner just
like in
elementary school classrooms if you have
all this beautiful bulletin boards i
actually taught middle school once upon
a time and i loved making awesome
bulletin boards and all sorts of
colorful things students actually do
less well in those classes than when
they have just plain walls
sad but true so
we but all this problem-solving stuff
besides taking down the pretty pictures
there are solutions right so socially
mediated learning environments peer peer
learning environments open-ended versus
closed-ended problems
interventions where you get students to
think about their own thinking
writing about how they're going to solve
a physics problem before they start
solving it
scaffolding like guides and prompts to
help
students right we move to expertise
by stretching a little but not
stretching too far
how do we help students get those right
steps the adaptive learning tools
that moocs have um the cognitive tutor
work that candace has done
all help with this kind of scaffolding
and then using multiple
representations but not just like
drawing you know four different
structures of benzene
on the board and being surprised the
students don't understand that they're
same thing even though you're smelling
the benzene by the time you're done
drawing it
we know a lot about effective
instruction and we're using
some of it in moocs but we could use
a lot more of it in moocs
almost all of it boils down to actively
engaging
students in their learning and i think
that's been the message
with all of my highlights of things we
know about learning is
when your brain is actively engaged
you're more likely to get
enduring understanding and we're
interested i hope in in deep
understanding not just
understanding to get you a good grade on
the exam and then you've forgotten about
it a week later which is what happens
in many many classrooms right now and
you know this is actually a conclusion
for the dieber report i thought i would
share with you that it's how the
technology is used i think that goes
without saying but
sometimes we forget that
there's a recent report that came out in
pnas
scott freeman and his colleagues did
where they took
on active learning across a whole range
of science
disciplines and all of these had shown
you there's some increase in learning
but they said well
okay let's take it a little bit further
again my question about why are we doing
this
why do we care and so they said well if
we look
at these studies and we do a
meta-analysis
can we show that there's any difference
in the success
of students do we retain more of the
students again candace's point
when she was welcoming us so here
they're looking at the percent
of students who fail a class
and then this orange curve here which
hides behind the blue
is a distribution of you know looking at
kind of the extent
of lecture activity so this is mostly
lecture
and this is mostly active learning and
so you're
much less likely to see failure
the drop fail withdrawal rates vanish
well they don't completely go away but
they get much smaller when active
learning is used in a classroom
and the other neat thing about the study
is they
looked at enough different research
papers
that they could break them down across
the science disciplines and again
they haven't looked further than that
and
over here is the decrease in the failure
rate so going to the right is a good
thing
fewer students fail and across all of
the disciplines
you see a decrease in fail rate so this
isn't something that just works well
if you're teaching chemistry it works
across the disciplines
now great study it's getting a lot of
play
since 1972 when cognitive psychologists
first did the work we've actually known
that actively engaging in learning is a
better way
to go we have thousands of studies we
have meta-analyses
we have national academy reports maybe
it's time to start doing something
the other thing right just and again i
think this is becoming a more familiar
story dan schwartz work out at
stanford where everybody's busy flipping
classrooms right it's a great thing
about a mooc you can go and
you know use it in a blended model and
flip the classroom
well there's there's
some ways that work better than others
to do this and
dan schwartz has talked a lot about this
time for telling
nice study looking at students learning
physics
and their ability to use physics in
later classes as well so the
transferability
if the students encounter a problem
first and they
struggle with it learning actually is
supposed to be a little hard if it's
easy you're probably not learning
if it's too hard you're probably not
learning either but hitting that sweet
spot
so if they struggle with the problem
first and
then come to class and someone helps
them understand
what to do their learning is more
effective
than if they watch a video of someone
explaining the whole concept
and then they come to class and do the
problem so
just simply tossing around the term
flipped classroom without unpacking and
thinking hard about what's happening
there is not a solution
okay i also wanted to build a case
for blended learning so i think moocs
are incredibly promising there's a lot
that we can
do there but moving into the blended
environment is something we want to
think about
so one of the questions that always
surfaces is what are the things that
you can't do in a mooc
and usually the answer is well can't do
yet because we're going to find
a way around it and there's all sorts of
social interaction tools there's amazing
things that people are starting to do
and i can't wait to hear about
more of them today but i'm going to
share a research example that i think
will get you
thinking about this a little bit so this
is susan fisher's work
we fund her work through nsf at depaul
university
and she's really interested in the
question of embodied cognition what if
you
physically interact with stuff and as
far as i know it's so
there there are potentially ways we
physically interact in a digital world
um
and and how do we think about this so
angular momentum if you have this
spinning wheel right you're holding a
spinning wheel
and you tip the wheel you actually feel
the torque you
feel the shift in the vector that's the
angular
momentum you physically feel it so she
did this
beautiful study where she used this
exercise
in a cl in a laboratory and
some of the students interacted with the
wheel and
physically felt the torque and some of
them observed
and then they asked them to solve a
range of problems including angular
mental problems
the ones that physically interacted did
better
then they took it one step further and
they put the students in an mri and did
functional mri to do the brain imaging
and so the students are in the mri i
don't know if i would have been a good
subject in this study or not but you're
in the mri
and you're solving these physics
problems you'd use your fingers to touch
the button to answer the questions so
you're not there's no gross motor
movement right you can't move around
much
in an mri so they're answering the
questions it turns out
the students that learn the concept by
physically interacting with it
they lit up different areas of their
brain when they went to
solve that problem later than the
students that
did didn't they just observed so there's
something different about that learning
we still have a lot
left to unpack
okay so then if we think about blending
for success i wanted to pull a couple of
examples from technical training in
community colleges where there's been
some very very interesting
work done so one welding simulators this
is a welding simulator here
going out and learning to weld right
really high temperature flames you can
hurt yourself
pretty quickly just like flight
simulators but this seemed a little
different than a flight simulator
there are welding simulators where
students are getting competency tested
and now the rules have changed in the
department of education you can actually
get
competency credit versus just you know
time
sitting in a chair in classrooms which
is a great thing
but here using a combination of
technology enhanced learning
skills to figure this out before you
set a student out in a dangerous
environment and there's a lot of work
going with
remote access especially nanotechnology
equipment atomic force microscope
scanning electron microscopes
so you could be in california and using
this
equipment remotely in a lab at penn
state there's
also some really really interesting
examples this is an automotive
technology training where there are
hybrid courses that have been developed
with industry so thinking about the role
of industry partners
and
community colleges and it's it's a
hybrid course it's continually
updated with quarterly conversations
with the industry partners
and the students you know are doing the
online work
but there's no way you know how to
interact with a robot
on the manufacturing floor unless you've
actually interacted with that robot
so there's ways for students even at
very um distant community colleges that
then come and spend time learning to
interact with that so how do we begin to
think more creatively if we're doing a
mooc how do we tie that to the other
pieces of learning and are there ways
that
with newly envisioned partnerships and
collaborations we might
be able to pull that off okay
so the other piece of this right i've
been
talking a lot about you know the one of
the parallel
tracks which has been what do we know
about learning can we bring that into
the mooc world
the other then which you we've got lots
of great sessions ahead of us
are you know what can we learn from
moocs and
how do we begin to fast forward
the research agenda so a year ago
the national science foundation and the
department of education through the
institute for
educational sciences release these
common guidelines
for education research and development
and i think they're really helpful frame
for us to consider they're bringing us
into a more everyday conversation
range so some of the things that came
out of this right are three basic
categories right there's this
foundational and early exploratory stage
research and then there's the design and
development stage and that's what i
think
most of us do we like to build things as
educators
and so we're building we're designing
you know we talk about being learning
engineers candace often talks about
learning engineers too
but in that iterative improvement cycle
we want to be learning
not just building so how today is we're
all together as both practitioners and
researchers
do we figure out how to work together to
build and learn together
and then what we want to do is have
impact so again
how do we think a little bit in a little
bit more fine-grained
way about this notion of scale
right what does scale mean and more and
more in education research we're
realizing there's adaption
adaptation there's when you go to
implement that what worked at
institution a
you know may generally work at
institution b but through like network
improvement community models
we're learning how to adapt it to that
specific student body it's not a one
size
fits all and i think that's the really
interesting and
very healthy tension we're experiencing
with moocs is we want to do it at scale
but we
also want to do it at a scale of one
one individual and make it work for that
person
so we want to know about efficacy
studies then
we have an ideal world right we can get
something great that works for mit
students and you know in the ideal world
of a circuits course here that's
terrific
but then we want to do an effectiveness
study and figure out how does this
work in the hands of students taking
circuits courses say at san jose state
how do we adapt how do we implement
what can we export wholesale and
effectiveness studies help us
unpack that and as we do that then we
can really begin the large-scale
scale-up work and there you've got this
great advantage with moocs right you can
do these a b
studies where one group gets this
intervention another group gets that
intervention we can
really really rapidly iterate because
this course gets
used over and over again you can have
this continuous
improvement cycle but we've got to
really rethink how we do research so
some of you may have seen this
helpful report out of the department of
education on expanding evidence
approaches
in learning in a digital world right so
we we have to keep moving ahead we can't
wait 10 years for
a randomized controlled trial because we
have students right here right now
that need us so how do we begin to
rethink research in a way that's really
high quality really credible
and moves at the rate that we need it to
remove i think that's an incredibly
important challenge we don't want to
reduce the quality
of the research but we don't want to let
perfection be the enemy
of the good there's real life
application here and we've got to
balance those too
so we also want to begin to answer
why questions often and i see this
a lot in my work at the nsf where we
have a long history of
investigators doing evaluation studies
they want to know at the end
did it work or did it not work and
that's
great but we want to know why it didn't
work so we could get it
to improve or why it did work so we can
share that knowledge so here's an
example and i thought i'd pull
one commercial one of you know getting
to what but not
quite the why questions yet um this is
from an introductory textbook that
mcgraw-hill publishes
and they have adaptive learning tools
and
thousands of students right are using
adaptive learning tools this rich
database and so what do you do with the
data
well the book is now designed so that
each section
is aligned with learning objectives at
all different levels in bloom's taxonomy
and the data is gathered as to which
sections
students are struggling with and this is
a type of heat map right so the
red areas here in the text are texts
that
tie to learning objectives and adaptive
learning assessment where students
really struggled across the
you know whole country and actually
internationally with students using this
so this is now being used as a way to
drive
the revision of the textbook which is
a neat idea because now you're jumping
over the middle man right historically
when
textbooks are revised and i know
textbooks are static in this dynamic
workbook world
but i think the concept applies to our
mooc courses as well
historically you had instructors provide
reviews so the instructors are speaking
for the students
and you never have a direct student
voice so now you have a direct student
voice
but think about what the author has to
do the only information the author has
is ha whatever i wrote here isn't
helping the student very much
is it because the questions aren't good
do we need better questions
does the text need to change what do we
need to do
so right now this is kind of in this
middle ground where the authors are
being asked to revise
you know spend more time here because
students didn't get it but they don't
know why
so i wanted to share that as an example
of how
important getting to the why is in doing
research
okay the other thing is what are the
questions we want to ask
so these are some of the research gaps
that
came out of the the dieber study the
disability-based education
research report and
these are areas where i think there's
you know some real promise with moocs so
studies of similarities and differences
among different groups of
students to date at the undergrad level
which is really different than the
research that's been done
in k-12 most of the research is done at
the level of a single
course in a and mortar classroom
and the average length of a study is
over
about one and a half courses
so short term and very specific
groups of students right institutions
vary in terms of the demographics
hard to make generalizations and again
if we're trying to reach
all students if we can begin to
disaggregate the data
that would be hugely important
there's some social science work for
example that shows that
what um effective study strategies for
middle class white males
don't work well for lower income
african american males in a classroom
they're actually counter
productive the kind of just work harder
beat your head against the wall strategy
that works for white males
from middle and upper income doesn't
work
for others so one example i alluded to
longitudinal studies
already how do we follow students over
time if we care about
transfer of learning which is one of the
holy grails of education
we really have to do more longitudinal
studies
fiscally that's really tough to pull off
in
funding agencies are there ways through
quasi-experimental designs that we can
do this with our online learning are the
ways we can actually follow
specific students as well as cohorts
you know we need a lot more basic
research on how
students learn we know a lot about
concepts that are
really really tough for students
but we don't know so much
about why those concepts are hard right
my dry ice example
are there ways i think some of the work
dave pritchard's been doing here at mit
to try to unpack
what's going on with students conceptual
understanding
that you can parse so many different
factors you can
you have the scale to do multi-factorial
analysis and begin to figure out
what it really might be that's causing
that misconception to persist and maybe
have a better chance to move forward
um we don't do so much across
disciplines
about cross-cutting practices
science practices other disciplinary
practices
we don't do as much with thinking about
cognitive processes
in looking at this is is that a way
moocs can help us
move forward and then our moocs
a great way if we got them right to do
some subversive faculty
development right so we know what to do
and we want to get it in practice and if
all these wonderful moocs are out there
emulating incredibly effective practice
can that get others to adapt that
practice can we
model for each other whether it's in our
mookie world or in our bricks and mortar
classroom this effective practice i
think already
most were pretty excited to see
conversations with colleagues about
teaching
that really hadn't happened before mooc
started and if again if that's one great
thing that comes out of this
thank you
disaggregating data again why do we
care why are we doing this who are we
concerned about
so this is i'll help you unpack this but
this is um from carnevale and stroll
in 2010 and it's
national center for education statistics
data that they've processed and
presented here
but this is looking at what happens
after high school
to really high ability students based on
sat scores high ability students
as a function of socio-economic status
okay so up here these are the students
that go on to attend
four-year colleges if you come from high
ses you are twice as likely as a student
from a low socioeconomic status group to
go on to a four-year
school if we look at two-year college
only
14 percent compared to 80 percent of
high ses students go to two-year
colleges
24 half of you know the number here
of low-income students are going to
community colleges
and then this is really startling right
six percent
versus 31 percent don't attend
college and just to underscore these are
the high
ability students these are students with
tremendous
academic promise so it's not that they
weren't able to academically there's
other constraints and
it's not clear that this is changing
with moocs is there a way that we could
really
use moocs to move on this not just claim
that's what we want to do
or that's what we're going to do but
really do it and demonstrate
that that was happening
okay so there's lots of things we need
and this is just
a wish list of topics i'm sure that
you'll touch on in many ways in your
conversation over the next two days
right but utilizing big data and big
data focused on a small number right we
want to in the end use big data to
personalize the learning of each student
and what do we do with our data
collection and our archiving how do we
make
data sets interoperable how do we share
data
with each other how do we deal with
privacy concerns the asilomar
compact that came out the work that i'm
the president's council advisors of
science and technology in the white
house
are working on lots of things that
we've got to really rethink in terms of
what happens with ferpa
irb how we interpret those in a way that
we
honor and respect the learner and we're
also learning and helping
that learner and future learners and
we really need to move on analytical
tools
combined with research methodologies so
it's not just the tools it's really
thinking hard about the design
as well as the tools and how do we get
tools
that are going after data that we
actually care a lot
about versus interesting but you know
kind of humble
data about you know how long a student
persists in a mooc which is interesting
but there's a lot more we need to do and
you know we can think hard there's a lot
known about quasi-experimental
design where you don't quite have a
control group but you do a lot of
propensity scoring you match
people based on a number of
characteristics as well as randomized
control
designs which are going to be really
tricky i think even in moocs to do
especially with privacy issues and all
how do we
you know compare our subjects what
information do we have available
and we're also going to have to think
hard about qualitative approaches right
so the appeal right scale we immediately
go
to quantitative approaches which we
ought to do
right that that's one of the huge
advantages but if we forget about doing
the qualitative analysis and going in
and
unpicking what's really going on in that
learner's experience
we're not going to have a whole picture
and then this is a plea to everybody
that
we need to grow a whole new field of
data scientists
at nsf one of our cross all of nsf
priority goals through 2015
is to figure out how we can support the
growth in the field of data scientists
in the national research traineeship
program in graduate education which is
the
has come after iger there's a track for
data scientists
if you're interested in that but
this piece is really important we
we need more data scientists generally
but we need our
best and our brightest data scientists
to think really hard
about education issues i you know i also
do
biology genomics research and that's a
really exciting and important
field i mean you can pick any field
where you need data science
but we need people with this combined
expertise and it's really important they
understand the education
and the education research think about
you know for those of you that have
followed in
human genomics the early work that was
done with
genome-wide association mapping trying
to understand
small variations in the dna that
for example would make certain
individuals
more susceptible to negative effects of
antidepressants
or certain individuals more likely to
respond to
chemotherapy treatment x for their
cancer than chemotherapy y
we started out with our statisticians
who were
phenomenal right really doing great
stuff and we had the
geneticists over here and they hadn't
figured out how to talk to each other
and really pull their expertise together
so some of the early stuff and across
all sorts of genomics fields
genome-wide association mapping
didn't give us quite the quality of the
answers we wanted or sometimes gave us
the wrong answers because we hadn't
gotten that diverse
expertise to work together and in
education it's going to be the same way
as the analytics are being developed
unless you get the teams with the
expertise together so that you're really
asking
the questions that you most want
answered
in a way that's going to be useful we're
going to miss an opportunity
okay so this is actually a figure
taken from candace there was a workshop
last summer
at the nsf sponsored by the office of
science technology
policy at the white house and nsf
looking at advancing technology enhanced
education
and the science and technology policy
institute put together
a report from this meeting but i thought
this was just such a nice way to capture
how everything fits together right so
we're really interested in developing
the learning models
but from those learning models we want
to get
data and we analyze the data and that
goes back and informs in a virtuous
cycle the iterative improvement of this
but the data's also going to inform our
learning theory
so it's not just about building a better
mouse trap right which is where
a lot of us want to go right can we make
it better and better but
learning from it right and in that
learning
sharing that learning so that others can
also
build an even better mousetrap and that
you can use
learning theory to design the technology
so we want to think about how
all these pieces live together in a
really synergistic way
okay that stippy report i thought i
would just share some of the
recommendations again it just might get
you thinking a little bit about this
but there really needs to be a much
clearer
research agenda you know as anatom
candice pointed out we're just getting
started as a community how does this
community
come together and build a really
transformative research agenda what
kind of new ways of operating
have to be created do we need hubs of
excellence where
that you know private and public
partnerships are coming together
in innovative ways and what would that
look like
how do we work across all of our federal
agencies to better
leverage this so we get greater
consistency
and again really pushing hard on what
kind of partnerships haven't we
imagined before that might allow us
to move this work forward so
what i want to do as we wrap up is
challenge you to think hard again
about what problem we're trying to solve
or what
problems and is it would it make sense
for the
community to really try to focus
in a few areas and get some traction so
i'm pulling an example
from the federal government last year
the the federal stem five-year strategic
plan for education
was released and the motivation behind
this plan
was to leverage federal resources for
greater impact on education writ large
and there is a large chunk focused on
undergraduate education
and the federal agencies actually are
meeting i convene that group so i can
tell you for sure they're meeting and
they're working really hard
to figure out how to do this together
the overarching goals
are to enhance these are stem goals
right so again
we could expand it more broadly i'm not
suggesting we focus all our energy
on on stem but that's the world i live
in so that's the example i'm drawing
enhancing stem experience for
undergraduate students
the white house has a goal of graduating
a million additional students over the
next 10 years that really have high
quality stem degrees
and this is a lot of text but there are
four strategic
objectives and i wanted to share them
with you and this is all
available you know online you just look
for the five-year federal
strategic plan for stem education but
there are four
areas that the federal agencies are
focusing on
and one is to increase the number of
evidence-based practices that are
actually being used in instruction
and i mentioned the scott freeman
article
and one of the nice things about the
scott freeman article is it
went in this is the meta-analysis
went in and analyzed the assumption
in a pcast report that led to this push
so the pcast report claims that we can
get 75 of the way
to a million more stem workers just by
integrating
evidence-based practices into the
classroom
and the rationale is that it would
decrease
the drop fail withdrawal rates right now
less than 50 percent of the students
that walk into
a college as an undergraduate and want
to major in a stem field
walk out four to five years later with a
stem degree
in hand and the evidence in place
suggests that much of that is because of
really poor experiences in our
introductory courses
so the meta-analysis went in and
actually modeled that and showed that
indeed that from all the studies that
are out there
that looks like it's a valid conclusion
so maybe if we're
aiming to improve retention in stem
courses we might want to think about
getting more evidence-based practices
into
moocs and there's a huge
push to improve the stem learning
experiences in two-year colleges they're
great places to learn many many of our
students from underrepresented groups
start at community colleges as do all
students half of all hispanic students
start
in community colleges and we've got to
do a much better job at the bridge
to the baccalaureate
and then a lot of focus on authentic
stem learning and research
experiences whether they're in research
labs
in industry for all undergrads including
pre-service teachers there's a big push
for pre-service teachers
to have this kind of experience as well
how do we
think about that and
are there ways that moocs prepare
students again that's why i mentioned
that hybrid model that the technician
training
program is doing you know do we just
write this off if we're talking about
moocs or do
are there some creative ways to move in
that arena
and then the really really sticky
mathematics
problem that 50 percent of students
coming into college
aren't prepared for college level math
and 80 percent of them
don't finish college so the work with
carnegie funding
and nsf funding that tony brick and the
carnegie
foundation are doing on statway and
quant way
have had tremendous success they went in
and they identified the 20
of the things you could change that
would lead you 80
of the way there to solving the problem
and now the success rate for students
in one semester in statewide or quant
way
is substantially better in terms of
retention
in college than students taking multiple
terms of other mathematics programs
erie treisman is now working with
mathways
which is an effort to not just increase
retention in college but increase
retention in stem fields
city college in new york has a very very
promising
set of approaches to dealing with this
problem is there a way again
in the world of moocs to make that kind
of learning even more broadly available
to others and with all of these we've
been funding some work
with using moocs for online professional
development of all kinds
are the ways we can use moocs to help
teachers
college instructors do a better job in
their classroom
as well so who is the book for
okay so just to close then
learning science can really inform
online learning
and we need to think harder about that
and i'm looking forward to the next two
days of thinking hard about that with
everybody
and then how is it that we can really
learn in this new world and really think
about new research paradigms
so look forward to engaging with all of
you thanks for listening
yes
how about in the back you can do
different who i don't know who has a
microphone
maybe nobody has a question hello hi
i'm here can you see me i'm sorry i can
see bright lights i apologize okay
sorry okay i'm varun
uh thanks for the very interesting talk
one of the things
which i was thinking about is that when
we are talking about learning
effectiveness
it also depends a lot on how the
assessment is being done
you know and if the learning is assessed
in the right way
is there a standardized way of how
assessment is being done across programs
online offline and if the assessment is
really not standardized and being done
the right way we can keep getting
different results
that's the first part of the question
and the second part is when you talked
about the effectiveness of quizzes
more than review of materials
to get better learning outcomes again
that would need for scalable
ways of assessment which are automated
so the importance of automated
assessments in being able to scale
learning
both formative and summative becomes an
important part of the whole
puzzle and finally that assessment also
acting as a signal
for getting the socio-economic benefit
of the learning which has happened
so any thoughts on these three related
questions standardization of assessments
doing it in an automated way and then
using it as a signal to join the whole
ecosystem
they're fantastic points right because
at the end of the day if the assessment
doesn't change
we're dealing with bright rational human
beings and they're driven by
the assessment and so there are a number
of things that are going on that i think
i want to i'll talk briefly about the
assessment and then i want to talk about
kind of the whole formative piece which
you know maybe in the end we get
completely rid of the
the summative assessment at the end but
um
right now one of the challenges when you
begin to scale things even you know if
you have students just in this classroom
if you want to do assessments that
aren't
bubble sheets one of the major barriers
to an instructor is i have to grade
all those exams so there are a number of
activities going on right
edx has some great things with machine
learning that they're working on we have
a project
at nsf that we funded that involves
university
michigan state university of maine and a
number
of other schools where they're doing
this
automated response so they're trying to
see what effect it has on faculty
practice
if they provide a tool that can go in
and evaluate
short answer questions
rather than the bubble sheets so it's a
professional
development effort to get faculty to use
the more evidence-based practices but in
a way that builds in
the supports and actually there are a
number of other initiatives so if we can
think about how to do
that assessment well then we're going to
be successful if we still do
low level check off the box questions
then we might as well
you know not spend all our time on the
beautiful stuff up front because it's
not going to
change anything the other piece i think
is
as we think about how we assess
i think we really should stand the whole
thing on its head
and there are so many ways with
simulations
with games with other things where you
build in assessment
all along the way and there's this
iterative
feedback right the student finds out
right then and there
if they got it or not and think about
video games right that's that's in there
all along if you're chasing gold coins
when my kids were little with mario
games sorry i don't do video games
anymore so my
technology is dated but um you know and
jumping over alligators and everything
you get feedback you get eaten by the
alligator right
so if you get that feedback while you're
doing it
everything we know about learning shows
that's going to have a much greater
impact on your long-term learning
and we know from things like in the
defense the department of defense
flight simulators work there's blue
shark in the navy
which is used to help people navigate on
aircraft carriers and everything
you want people to have this real world
virtual experience and you want to get
input along the way too
so if you're learning to fly
a jet you can use sensors right to
detect
body temperature sweat other things you
want to know if someone's going to go
and fly this
jet in a difficult situation how are
they going to respond under stress
not how are they going to respond you
know in a very relaxed chilled
environment where they're you know
playing a video game
so getting that kind of feedback i think
we really want to push
the technology but i agree with you
completely unless we address the
assessment question
from the get-go we might as well all go
home
okay um i'm raki hassan um i have a
question about
teaching strategies that you mentioned
uh you already mentioned that
teaching strategies and techniques that
work for
white males students does not really
work for uh african-americans some right
i mean i
study one study the problem is there
isn't enough
at the undergrad level there isn't
enough research out there
okay my question is um most of the moocs
have begun with the promise of being an
international resource for
people all over the world and i guess
most of the students of the moocs are
from outside the united states
so has there been any studies that look
at what kind of teaching strategies work
for people from such diverse backgrounds
just in international backgrounds uh
do all is is possible to design a
strategy that works for people from all
cultures
all languages and so on
so really great question again we have
very little in the way of comparative
studies at the undergrad level we have
some on lab learning with the uk
and australia the oecd because of the
nape
pisa other international exams
we know a bit more at the k-12 level
so again i think one of the things we're
going to just
keep uncovering are these huge gaps
there's a program called pyre p-i-r-e at
nsf that funds
research and i think there's real
opportunities for people to do this
comparative
analysis i spent some time in egypt
not long ago and the one thing i heard
over and over that they're so concerned
with their
engineering programs because their
students are the best memorizers
in the world they are phenomenal
memorizes but
how do they shift their education
culture
so that people become more innovative
right so
folks look to the us as being a great
place
for innovation i don't think we can
really articulate
what it is we do educationally that
pushes
on innovation but we certainly value it
so we know there's differences and we
need to understand and especially in the
k-12 arena that for years
back when i was getting certified be a
teacher in the 70s in k-12
i took a whole course on cross-cultural
educational comparisons it's not that
the field doesn't exist
it's just we as undergrad folks haven't
tapped into it
so we don't need to go reinvent a field
but we need to work with colleagues that
have that expertise
um hello oh hi sorry the lights are
really bright so
you all look like just bright white
lights to me
you're glorious ironically i wanted to
ask about the same thing
uh which you'll probably now remove from
the presentation but
um i wanted to know also about the
statement of
uh you're mentioning white males like
certain demographics uh learned
in different ways and perhaps we could
tailor the way that we
teach to different demographics and i
wanted to sort of just
ask you on a shift of thinking sort of a
reverse look
more colloquial like the band-aid
treating the
the effects instead of the cause do you
think
do you think perhaps that it's not that
a demographic affects the way that
people learn but instead
the the environment in that demographic
and a lot of factors affect the way that
people learn and so
what i wanted to ask you is do you think
perhaps treating the cause
whatever that is i don't know is a
different way of thinking that might be
better and also
how moocs could play that role and the
role that moose could have instead
they're re really really good points
well taken i think
you know the broad point you're making
is how do we
look at diversity and historically we
have
looked at it as a problem you know with
folks from
different democrats something to be
fixed and that's really an unhealthy way
and a disrespectful and not helpful way
to look at it right what we really want
to know is how do we
benefit from the range of expertise
that's out there
from all people and that the greater the
diversity we have
working on problems together the more
likely we are
to be successful and so we
want to develop strategies that are
very inclusive there's also a lot of
places where you can learn a lot about
this there
is a long history of funding and
historically black colleges and
universities
tribal colleges and universities and
there is a wealth of expertise
there that we tend not to tap into or
tends to be
more siloed but your point is so well
taken to do anything that suggests
a band-aid approach is is
not not the way to go
uh hi i'm chinmaya from stanford so
regarding that point about uh diversity
uh i feel like the mooc environment
brings you
a different kind of diversity that you
haven't seen in person classrooms so far
uh you have people from entirely
different continents in the same class
and i think part of what you talked
about tailoring
pedagogy to suit demographics
probably takes away from this enormous
opportunity we have of using students to
teach each other
and especially students who are so
diverse from each other
so i wonder if you have any thoughts on
the trade-offs that you would be making
if we tailor versus
if you can get students to teach each
other in a pure learning way
yeah no i think it's an amazing
opportunity right and i think about all
any of us can say
at this point is there is an incredible
opportunity
i think there's very interesting things
to think about all the
work claude steele and others have done
on stereotype
threat does the online environment
remove some of that stereotype
threat right and you you can be who you
want to be right if you're
a woman you could decide that online
right you want to be
a guy and does that change
how you experience that setting
great important thoughts it's a
wonderful research agenda that
that's building here and and
what you know as we think so hard we
want to educate even if you think about
in the us
we want to educate people that are going
to be able to work in the global
workforce
and what does that mean so in one of our
technician training programs
there's this virtual entrepreneurial
system that's been set up and students
in the us work
on developing a virtual business with
students in china
and eventually they go and meet up and
they work together but they're working
on a shared project with a common
interest they're leveraging
each other's expertise and
it's pretty exciting to see so
i mean i think it's folks in your
generation that are going to help us
figure out how to do this
excellent excellent i'd love to learn
more about it
i um an el wang from columbia teachers
college um
i thank you for a great talk i have a
question about when you mentioned about
the uh not yet available for moocs when
you introduce several
learning science research studies
including the embodied cognition studies
so i wanted to ask what are some of the
uh
indicators you would want to introduce
to both
researchers and instructors to see where
are the
research results and studies out there
that has a potential
to join the mooc research studies
environment that we can look forward to
to learn or you know replicate the
studies in the
environment ah so
you're you're asking where if you're
you're developing
look where you could go and find
resources is that the ques
are ways we could yeah some of the trees
that see
the embodied cognition studies and some
other studies
are done in a traditional online setting
not necessarily in
the mooc world but they are potentially
really helpful
if we can replicate that so there are a
lot of them
out there um what would be your you know
top
two or three choices say if we want to
find something out there to give us
you know not just replication but some
inspiration
what would be some of the features you
would want to
well to put it in simply why would you
select
um the studies you showed in your
presentation what are some of the
commonalities you would give us
okay so where i
started right we we want to start
someplace where we have
a synthesis of what we know right
because if you're going to
pick something and go and put it in this
environment and scale
the gecko i would go with things that
there's evidence for
um that doesn't mean we shouldn't try
great ideas right because if we just
stick with what we know we're not going
to get any place
but i think in the early days when
you're starting to mooc you should build
on what we already
know and i think these strategies for
engage student learning using
peer learning doing problem solving
where there's
real opportunities for students to be
metacognitive and think about their
learning creating environments against
that kind of work where you write about
a problem before you just start
throwing equations at it um
so purely there's a whole range of them
there's actually
so a couple places i would go the
national academies have
they're following up on this discipline
based education research report with a
practitioner volume
and it should be out this fall and it's
full of case studies across a range of
different disciplines about effective
strategies so they've gone in and
they've picked across the whole
suite of strategies those that appear to
have the greatest impact
based on the data and they walk you
through
how to implement them and what to look
for and when it doesn't work the first
time right because
lots of things don't work the first time
because there's many dimensions
how to not give up but go back and try
it again i
i would work with things that come from
there things like the um
the pod network which focuses on faculty
development there's a lot of great stuff
there
um the how learning works out of
carnegie mellon
really terrific synthesis
of what's there and then i would also
read
well it sounds like you're interested
that you're from the practitioner
perspective right is that your question
both from the research perspective i
would dig into that report that
just came out from the department of
education about expanding research in
the digital world
i think it really gets you thinking hard
about
what could you do differently right
because you the idea
maybe the baby step is first you
implement practices that look like they
work but
that's kind of a waste of opportunity to
just do that i hear you saying you want
to go further right you want to take
this
and build on it so i think you want to
iterate the the research strategy
thank you susan i have a couple of
announcements to make
uh if you signed up for to want into
dinner ticket to the
event tonight uh everybody who signed up
has dinner tickets available
so please go to the uh desk and you can
pay and get a dinner ticket
for tonight's event uh also
when we teach we try to bribe and
intimidate our students to sit in the
front
and there's bunch of empty rows in here
and then everybody's sitting in the back
and i hope going forward that that
people will actually come and sit in the
front
and and don't keep this front empty we
have a lot of seats available in the
front especially in this one
and the other rooms you go they are
somewhat smaller so you might have to
freely pack the room so
so make sure that there's no empty
spaces next to you so practice inside so
people
don't have to stay in the stand in the
back thank you
you